thanks sherry so the nutcracker it's
always a holiday favorite for all of us
but unfortunately not
at the smith center this year because of
the pandemic but there is a new exhibit
it gives you a rare look at the costumes
and the set pieces up close
hector mejia live inside the discovery
children's museum all dressed up hey
hector you look good
audrey stop thank you alex and you know
what this is actually a real piece from
the production the las vegas production
is actually
one of the most unique in the entire
country and here in las vegas
we have a chance to come on down to the
discovery children's museum
and get really close to all of these
pieces
this is a really neat thing that says
what is this here we have roy
with the nevada valley theater to
explain what we have here
this is uh harlequin here and columbine
his partner over here and they're two
dolls
that come to life in the party scene and
uh just like magic just like magic
and they do a little dance for the kids
in the party scene
and then sitting in the middle is all
this is a dancing bear and all of these
pieces
are from the production they are from
the actual show
yes and in non-pandemic years
we wouldn't have the opportunity to do
something like this but since we're not
able to perform next door at the smith
center we're really happy to have this
opportunity
with discovery people be able to come in
and see
the actual pieces from the show this
looks realistic
this is the rat queen this is the rat
queen up here
looking down at you there she is there
she is
rat queen and then her her rat minions
here
uh they play a very important role in
the battle scene they get in a fight
they get in a fight they're getting a
fight with the nutcracker over here and
there is a nutcracker
and they're kind of scary this morning
yeah he's uh he
does have a little scary well he's got
to fight he's look what he's got to
fight
oh yeah she is not pretty she's not
pretty so
uh yeah this is our little this is all
from that battle scene
does the cannon uh obviously he's got a
sword in the cannon and
i can't i can't i don't want to spoil it
i can't tell you who wins but
uh it's very exciting tell us you know
quickly
what makes the las vegas production so
unique and stand out
well i think the the first thing is just
the scope of it i mean it was built
the first year that the smith center
opened and the smith center such a
wonderful venue
and huge huge stage space so when james
canfield created this
uh this production in 2012
he really wanted to use all the space so
it's
it's really truly larger than life thank
you for having us sorry in the morning
and alex
i'm not talented enough to dance so i
guess
i'll have to settle for being a
mannequin i guess
and just standing here hector i've seen
you dance
that i do not agree with that you are
great
thank you so much it's so cool to see
that stuff up close you're welcome have
fun out there